dude so i was listening to uh two bears
one cave
you guys are my faves and what you call
warren sapp
and tom's idea time's like dude called
warren sap every episode
he goes yeah it's not gonna answer
warren answer
calls you brett whatever whatever with
warren sapp hall of famer
and you guys convinced him to start a
football podcast on mondays during the
football season two bears one stop
two bears one set which i love i was
like dude i want [ __ ]
andy because there's nothing i don't
have any like
last time cal was here i'm talking
sports i'm like yeah he doesn't know any
sport there's nothing
i don't know yelling at him i don't know
football the way tom tom really knows
football time no football yeah you and
tom know football i may not be the right
guy for the podcast
luckily i know warren sapp [ __ ] yeah you
do
he was in though dude he texted me this
morning
and he's like because i on the because
he finally listened to the podcast and
it's
tom and i do our podcast as if no as if
we don't realize
the people were trashing are listening
right i know so like we trashed
[ __ ] i think we tried stacks shepard
once just not but like
not in a bad way but just like fun just
having fun busting balls and you don't
think they're gonna hear it and then
jack sheppard sent me a [ __ ] shirt
for his podcast and i was like oh [ __ ]
i like zack sheppard a lot he has a
great podcast he's a great [ __ ]
podcast
armchair expert's great do we we uh
we did this thing this last podcast we
talked about meeting jennifer aniston
did you see that
no it's the hardest i've ever laughed
it's the hardest i've ever laughed in my
life
without it did it take you and tom
sawing to do a podcast game you guys are
best friends
you know you guys are doing your own
thing but it's like
i don't know you and bird get together
before you and tom so
bur and i ber and i were doing one
because i mean i was
real inside baseball but please it's
there uh there was
i don't know how much i can say about it
but like but burn
there was an opportunity at all things
comedy that i wasn't interested in
but i felt obligated as a member of all
things comedy because you should
participate
these are burning you're showing i knew
something's burning there and and there
was a podcast opportunity that i didn't
want i didn't want i'm trying to be safe
but didn't want birdcast to be involved
in
cast that's something it's my own thing
and it's doing its own thing it's part
of all things comedy but
as far as advertising wise i'm very
happy where i was at but we had this
really great opportunity and i didn't
want to
i didn't want to end something working
well to and so i said to bill
i don't want to bring bert cast over
there but i don't want to lose this
opportunity
and he was like i understand well let's
do one together let's just do one
episode
to maybe jump start things see if we
like it we did one and we had a [ __ ]
we really had a blast i mean
i don't know you and bill were that
close i've known bill for 20
about 20 years and and i and i'm the
biggest fan of bills like
well he's i mean top three easily and by
the way and
i got to tell you bill you know i'm of
those cigarette in top five
i mean segura so shagura has the best
special this year i think
oh he and the fact that he didn't get
nominated for a [ __ ] emmy get the
[ __ ] out of here asinine i mean look all
the emmy nominations were fantastic i
know he's our boy i'm telling you if you
haven't seen
tom segura's special dude his dude it
[ __ ]
bang it's bangs he'll be doing arenas
next year but uh
he he him and bill like we did i didn't
want bill and then as
soon as i did one bill i was like i i
released tom and i
talked to him i was like dude we got to
do a podcast we've always talked about
doing a podcast
and he was like let's do one and then so
bill and i did one but we didn't release
it for like
six months oh wow and so tom and i
started ours
and then ours started gaining traction
and and all things comedy is like you
know you and bill have a great
chemistry it's not even that we have a
great chemistry i i think we really love
you like i love being with bill
and bill gets a kick out of me and so
and bill's not the like
easiest person to talk to for most
people like but like obviously i've
brought it up on our podcast but like
him and theo is like the most
notoriously awkward
podcast which i just go that's bill burr
like yeah bill's the only you know i've
been around some
tough guys man bill's the only guy where
i am i watch my p's and q's and i get
quiet
bill bill scares me i think because i
have so much respect for him
but he's also such a [ __ ] killer you
know
i remember one time i wore a a jumpsuit
to the comedy store
i wore a jumpsuit i didn't know bill was
gonna show up i wear a [ __ ] jumpsuit
like an [ __ ]
and i was so excited about it finally
comes and i wear it and we're in the
green room and everybody's there and
rogan's there and rogan and
dalia and callum give me [ __ ] for him
like oh god damn and they're just
roasting me
and bill walks i'm like [ __ ] my life
dude
and bill looks at me makes fun of me but
then he sticks up for me i'm like yeah
[ __ ] yeah well that's the thing about
bill and this is when he walked down i
was so scared i'm like
[ __ ] this is this is my breakdown of
bill and i know bill won't see this but
i know if he did see this this would
bother him
but this is my breakdown of bill so many
people respect bill
and call him top three uh myself
interesting did you know that
you think he i think he knows it i think
he ignores it and i think he thinks it's
[ __ ]
i think he but and that's why he's a
goat that's why yeah that's why he's
the best we got yeah and so what happens
is people try to try to predict
what he's gonna how he's gonna react to
be on his side
to jam with him and to try to take them
and he doesn't like that
he builds a contrarian first and
foremost
i will tell bill things i know he said
to me
sometimes and he'll just take the
opposite side just for [ __ ] fun
just because that's why his brain works
his brain is so
[ __ ] quick that it it breaks things
apart
and and he's a [ __ ] great guy to do a
podcast with because
you just bring up a thing like uh bill
any time zone you could go to any time
period any
any car what car would you want to drive
brand new car brand new car but you go
to that time period
and what song would you listen to and
all of a sudden his brain goes oh like i
was talking to him the other day and he
was like
i go all the people you'd want to meet
and he's like oh the people from the
fantastic
or the the mar the furious seven or some
movie from the yeah what people call it
and
just his brain is just different and
he's fun as [ __ ] to talk to and then
different but theo's the same way for me
theo's kind of
where i can bring up a subject and i
know it's just going to open up the
[ __ ] floodgates yeah and then we're
off to the races and with tom
i sincerely knows me probably better
than my wife like he knows me so well
that there are and he knows me so well
and he knows how to make me laugh
like he's made me laugh harder than any
human being this
i swear to god i swear to god when we
did
this last week that's out right now we
talked about
the possibility of meeting jennifer
aniston you didn't
we did why because he told me some
[ __ ] story about meeting jennifer
aniston and then he met her
yeah he told me he did and then i got
really involved in this
in this in the story and then okay so
someone else
like uploaded it i don't know if you
want to play from the this guy's clip
it's [ __ ] i don't care
it's just if you play tom don't flag our
[ __ ] podcast don't show them
don't you i'll i'll give you the
breakdown of it because
it's so much better because this guy
tells he tells me this long-winded story
about me and john branston that i buy
and then he tells me it's a lie and i go
oh [ __ ] afterwards afterwards and then i
said
i said you know just so you know in the
future we should make a pact
that like if we ever get to meet a
famous person like if they want to meet
us
we bring the other person great idea and
he yeah right it's like
we help each other i mean it's based off
a movie premise that we're trying to
pitch we're trying to sell
of us becoming best friends with johnny
depp and so
yeah yeah and so so he says great
so we are dumb as [ __ ] so which i love
so then tom's i said to tom if we get a
chance to meet jenna anderson
where should we meet her and he goes
well probably at like one of our houses
like we're not in my house we're not
going to fit
and i go we're not doing your house i go
let's do her house yeah he's like good
call and i go should we bring our wives
he's like [ __ ] no no
and i go can she bring a dude he goes
probably for safety and then he
immediately shifts and he goes
maybe that's the wrong message and i
laugh
for seven if you just go to two bears
one cave
one minute i think 20 one hour
20 minutes in if you go to two bears one
cave it is
i swear to god it's the hardest i've
ever laughed
one minute 20 one hour 20 minutes 40
seconds
i love that tampa bay hat too that's a
great tampa bay sent that to me
you'll hear the hardest i've ever
laughed in my life
okay keep going forward keep going
forward scroll scroll you'll see my face
wince up you'll see my face wince up
keep going
keep going no no that's how i cut off a
skin tag keep going keep going
yeah this isn't a political podcast by
the way if you want science or anything
intelligent
wrong podcast keep going keep going way
far way far way far way far you'll see
my face winds up
no keep going way far way far i was
wrong on time
keep going keep going keep going there
you go hit here
okay so a little bit before that then
you're crying
yeah so if you want to have a couple of
security people there
[Laughter]
they're dying
but if you want just go back go back go
back and pitch and if you watch
tom's delivery this is what i love about
him because he doesn't do we just want
to do like brunch with her
okay watch this just watch tom's
delivery okay it's kind of
like crunch you know presumptive to say
we have to be at your house
yeah i mean like we just want to how
about we just want to have lunch we're
not coming to my [ __ ] house we can't
fiddle well i'm just saying though we
can't you can you know to
to is meeting someone is me his delivery
is what kills me
gotta be at her house or your house okay
do we invite her to your house
sure no we go to her house okay how
about we we say we bring our wife
[Applause]
no watch this watch this this is what
kills me that's good
she can can she bring a dude for safety
that's the wrong message
it's dangerous you should protect
yourself we're dangerous
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
we understand that you might feel
threatened in our presence so if you
want to have a couple of security people
that's a good idea you're just so silly
man
okay okay okay there is seven minutes
ago like this so
it's you like this this is a message to
everyone
who wants to cancel comedy okay oh this
is who was very handsome
[ __ ] everyone's going after everyone
these days cancel cancel cancel
[ __ ] off this is if you don't like it
just don't watch
okay just tap out because we need this
i'm going to tell you a real quick story
that is very poignant and i'll probably
tell this on two bears one cave next
week
but so if you're hearing it twice so we
put our dog down
uh sunday sunday afternoon [ __ ] the big
dog big dog big
dude he was great what happened she was
[ __ ] the
greatest yeah the best so friendly blood
caught in her heart
due to an aggressive cancer was bleeding
out into her lungs
and was losing it wasn't that old of a
dog
nine
five knee surgeries health problems kids
are messed up right
oh bro your daughters are not doing well
it was that was really
really really tough daughters have a
definitely bring home a puppy but yeah
oh yeah yeah
oh yeah oh we've already got a couple
lines you know what's going on uh and
we're gonna name them priscilla
one and two and it's i'm not a great
parent and so plans enforced all right
so it's been rough and and
and especially like not everyone doesn't
know how to and no one has laughed
so last night we're at dinner and
georgia says hey someone told me
something about jennifer aniston today
one of her friends and i went oh yeah
she goes what is it i said
something from two bears one cave now
mind your family hasn't laughed yet
right like we're still mourning this dog
how long has it been uh at least 20 over
24 hours so probably like
oh heavy like it's been it's been really
heavy
because you take a turn and where you'd
see the dog laying on the couch you see
the
imprint of a body but you don't see the
dog and when you get up in the morning
you don't see that it's it's not just
it's
dogs are so much in your life that you
don't even know like it's
this is why i don't want a dog hey man i
don't wanna deal with this i'm not gonna
lie to you
i would argue you shouldn't have kids
either who wants all these [ __ ]
responsibility and all these things that
you
that cause vulnerability in your life
like having children having dogs having
all these things
when she left and and she there was a
void in our house i mean
it's and it's just so heavy you're in
the same house same house i'm getting
out of it asap
[ __ ] that house i'm done with it you
have to i can't live in the house
anymore
i just can't you guys gonna tom no you
but we've talked about just [ __ ]
renting and just
renting our house out and just getting
out of it because it's like but we're
not we're building a new house right now
and so we're same area
same area and and pris was lucky enough
to play
in the yard of the new house because we
have the house so we have memories of
chris at the new house and
this old house is prisa's house when we
got the house
brought priscilla she's there until like
practically move out it's her house
that's her house yeah you gotta get out
so we're sitting at dinner and georgia
says what's this about jennifer aniston
and i said oh yeah it's from two bears
one cave
and she says everyone says it's pretty
funny and i said yes it's that's funny
and so i go back to the man cave to work
out
and i come back in and check and the
girls are in the bedroom and they're
watching it
they're watching the clip someone sent
them do they usually watch or no
they have watched they watch kool-aid i
don't know if you've heard about i drink
a gallon of kool-aid a day
and so that's a very funny clip too so
tom found out to drink a gallon of
kool-aid every day they're so ridiculous
so they watch kool-aid and them for
whatever reason
them watching me and tom laugh makes
them laugh yeah there's one
thing where tom talks about get fired
where i spit a drink out of my mouth and
i fall on the ground
there's a time when we we did we did we
said uh
we did fallon questions to each other we
interviewed because we weren't going to
do fallon because of the covid
so we did fallon questions were you
supposed to do
no i mean maybe but we never did
anything because there was no [ __ ]
yeah
so and one of the questions were uh what
are your three favorite dwarfs
anyway what are your three of your
favorite seven dwarfs but i
thought he just meant name your free
three favorite dwarves
that was like peter dinklage wee man and
brad and brad williams
and there's only three i know yeah tom's
going like what [ __ ] answers
that and he was like sleepy sneezy and i
was like oh i heard the question wrong
so they whenever those clips happen the
girls
their friends the boys that watch our
podcast that are like high school
seniors or whatever
we'll send them to georgia georgia watch
them yeah
so i come in i'm going isla's got a
refrigerator in a room and i go to get a
soda out of it
because that's the only place we can
keep sodas and georgia and isla
are in their bedroom with leanne
watching that clip of jennifer aniston
and they're crying laughs and i went i
took a second and i went
i'm very lucky that i have a job that if
you're going through some bad [ __ ]
if you by the way that's my job right so
my job isn't to tell you how we do it
yeah it isn't tell you science
it doesn't tell you politics no it isn't
to tell you anything i can't talk about
sports really i wish i could like i
literally was in the shower thinking
about this today and i was like
like you're lucky that you can talk
legit about
uh when i by the way when i say shower i
was in my outdoor shower i was uh
you're lucky you have a few ski skill
strengths like you can talk about
mma knowledgeably you can be funny as
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like there's like you can do a couple
different things i can
only do comedy i can't talk about like
so i don't have like a bunch of skill
sets however that one skill set i got
where i for whatever reason that i can
be in the moment and be real and
and find funny things to be funny about
if you're going through some [ __ ] like
you lost a dog
or your parents are in covid or whatever
you're the guy
the pot whatever i can do is i can get
you out of that i can get your mind off
it
for like 15 minutes i can give you 15
minutes break and for some people
and for my family last night it was so
important because this morning
last night leanne slept in bed with isla
because she didn't want to be in the bed
because
chris usually sleeps with us so she
slept in bed with isla georgia slept in
her room and they all woke up this
morning
and there was a different energy in the
house and i went like
i went i'm not saying it was because of
that podcast definitely the fact that
they were all on that side of the house
yeah and they all [ __ ] hung out there
and i
i went out to the treadmill worked out
came in got the pool to went to bed
did my own thing it was i had radio at
like six in the morning so they wanted
to be away from me
that's what is important about these
[ __ ] podcasts and stand-up comedy
huge
and it's like listen i'm by the way i'm
defending hannah gatsby on this [ __ ]
like if you're getting upset about
hannah
what did she say no i'm just saying like
people want to take down hannah gatsby
who gives a [ __ ] yeah who gives a [ __ ]
who cares i like her last hour
like yeah but who gives a [ __ ] and i'm
saying that to our fans that go like
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] what you know something
there are meatheads listening it's going
[ __ ] hannah gatsby
dude just don't care for you it's not
for you why do you why do you have a
why do you care yeah that's my thing is
like me too i just like i don't
understand it
if that's not your cup t just go just
change the channel yes
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been
[ __ ] doing